moron
welcome and some are still currently
constituted organs press conference the
dark so T Chennai or Isabel 3c facility
Alameda scene for Somali community Mira
Thornton or visitor fool and playing
Elsa and Eagle photo scroll Estelle of
Ruby revenues svenska a warm welcome to
Karolinska Institute and today's press
conference the Nobel assembly has
concluded its meeting and we are ready
to announce this year's Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine I'm John Hanson
Secretary of the Nobel assembly and with
me or professor Julian see red chair of
the Nobel Committee and professor
joining a hunter of the Nobel assembly I
will start by reading the announcement
in five languages will distribute a
press release
professor c-rad will introduce the
science behind the prize and we'll take
questions and after that it will be
opportunities for interviews with Nobel
Committee members for those who have
requested that Nobel for shambling in
the Karolinska Institute the oradour
Basu that sugar and retreat on ocean
Belle trees officially given me the
scene Timmy and some killed Ellis James
Rothman Randy Schekman
for Thomas zhulov further ado protector
program the machinery yet some rigged
Lehrer the signal traffic it Vicki
transport system libera salva the Nobel
assembly at Karolinska Institute as
today decided toward the 2013 Nobel
Prize in Physiology or medicine jointly
to James Rothman Randy Schekman
and Thomas hood off for their
discoveries of machinery regulating
vesicle traffic a major transport system
in ourselves
a new belt exam um Karolinska Institutet
Reuter flossin the Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine food as a our
5000 rights in the mines a man James
Rodman Randy Schekman Thomas Rudolph
foodie and takumin with a fancy
machinery hidden the sickle carry guilt
Invictus transport system enhancements
Ellen to collide blossom Playmobil the
last ad Karolinska the city zoo the PBL
Aquino Bell the physiology of the
medicine
Demetrius confront more a James Rothman
Randy Schekman
head trauma pseudo who knows de Cuba
relative Oh mechanism gracious on the
traffic basically in system the Transpo
essencial de nozzoli novelettes care
some Leia richelene scope Institute
restless ammonia prestige noble else
keyframe you official Augie eliminates
in revenue James Rothman Randy Schekman
he trauma suit off though treaty Robles
T regular admired Virginia to the court
was not Noah transport noises DME clear
car thank you that I'd like to invite
protect Julie in see read to present the
new Nobel laureates and their discovery
Julian please
thank you your honor good morning
everyone
so here are the 2013 Nobel laureates in
Physiology or medicine on the left is
Professor James Rothman from Yale
University New Haven Connecticut USA in
the center is Professor Randy Schekman
University of California Berkeley USA
and on the right is Professor Thomas
suit off
Stanford University's School of Medicine
Palo Alto California USA
over the next few minutes I'll give you
some background information about their
discoveries the 2013 Nobel laureates
have been interested in questions
related to fundamental cell physiology
this slide shows a schematic
representation of a cell this cell could
be any cell from the body one of the
greatest mysteries of cell physiology
was how the right substances could be
delivered to the right destinations at
the right time how our molecules such as
hormones transport proteins or
neurotransmitters correctly routed to
their appropriate destination and how is
this process controlled with temporal
precision the 2013 Nobel Prize honors
three scientists who have solved the
mystery of how the cell organizes its
transport system each cell of the body
has a complex organization that
separates specific cellular functions
into compartments this
compartmentalization vastly improves the
efficiency of many cellular functions
and it prevents potentially dangerous
molecules from roaming freely within the
cell molecules are transported around
the cell in small bubble-like vesicles
shown here in this slide in blue these
vesicles shuttle their cargo between
different compartments in the cell this
inset zooms in on vesicles that have
been routed to the cell membrane it
shows a vesicle docking infusing with
the membrane so it can deliver its cargo
to the outside of the cell the three
Nobel laureates have discovered the
Maalik the molecular principles that
govern how this molecular cargo is
delivered with
decision to the right place at the right
time in the cell location and timing are
everything Randy Schekman studied how
the cell organizes its transport system
in the 1970s he studied the genetic
basis for this transport process using
yeast as a cell model this slide depicts
vesicle transport in normal yeast cells
on the left and in mutant yeast cells on
the right sheckman identified yeast
cells with defective transport machinery
the blue bubble like vesicles piled up
in certain parts of the cell Schekman
found that the cause of this congestion
was genetic and he went on to identify
the genes that mediate specific steps in
vesicle transport
james rodman also studied the nature of
the cells transport system this slide
shows a vesicle at three different
stages in the transport process it also
shows the membrane of the cell in the
1980's and 1990's Rothman discovered
specific proteins pictured here on the
vesicle in orange and the membrane in
orange as well these specific proteins
form a complex enabling vesicles to fuse
with their target membranes shown here
in the center in the fusion process
proteins on the vesicle and target
membranes bind to each other like two
sides of a zipper this ensures that the
vesicle fuses at the right location and
that the cargo molecules can be
delivered to the correct destination but
questions still lingered how is the
release of the cargo controlled in such
a precise manner
Thomas sued off he was interested in how
nerve cells communicate with one another
in the brain and how signals instruct
vesicles to release their cargo with
precision in the 1990s he searched for
calcium sensitive proteins that control
this process he identified molecular
machinery shown here in purple that
senses calcium ions and triggers vesicle
fusion calcium binds to this machinery
and triggers the complete fusion of the
vesicle with the target membrane suit
offs discovery explained how temporal
precision was achieved and how vesicles
could rapidly release their cargo upon
command
all right so this slide was showing
animation of the machinery regulating
vesicle traffic the vesicle and the
membrane are shown the vesicle is routed
towards its membrane proteins on the
vesicle and the membrane bind to each
other like two sides of a zipper the
vesicle fuses with the membrane once the
vesicle is in position it must wait
until calcium enters the cell calcium
binds to a molecular sensor on this
complex and that explains how temporal
precision is achieved and how signaling
substances can be released from the
vesicle on command the vesicle transport
system is critical for a variety of
physiological processes ranging from
signaling in the brain to release of
hormones to release of immune cytokines
without this wonderfully precise
organization the cell would lapse into
chaos defective vesicle transport occurs
in a variety of diseases including a
number of neurological and immunological
disorders as well as in diabetes the
2013 Nobel laureates have discovered a
fundamental process of cell physiology
their discoveries have had a major
impact to advance the understanding of
the machinery regulating vesicle traffic
a major transport system in the cell and
here once again are the 2013 Nobel
laureates in Physiology or medicine
thank you for your attention
the taa Nobel Committee so random talk
invaded our career at Stella frugal time
for questions we would like to start you
are all stunned
or perhaps you all hadn't expected us
what did they say well to be honest I
have been able to reach Randy Schekman
and James Rothman and they were both
delighted surprised happy delighted to
share with to others in this combination
and they look forward to coming to
Stockholm unison had they been
collaborating scientifically yes I think
Rothman and Jackman have been
collaborating right well they started
their work all independently and it was
very interesting that the work of
sheckman and yeast and the work of
Rothman and mammals and they were aware
of each other's studies and so that led
to collaborations later and I don't
believe that they have collaborated with
suit off so that's a complimentary line
of research could you say something
about clinical use of this research for
instance what kind of medications have
been created from this I think the last
clinician yawning a hunter to comment on
that so first of all we have to realize
that this is a price on on physiology on
cell physiology but these beautiful
discoveries have importance for
understanding of the human body and
obviously implications for diseases in
various organs such as the nervous
system diabetes and immune disorders
could you perhaps give us an example or
I know that it's used in Diagnostics is
well yes so there are setup of
authentications first of all we can
think of tetanus tetanus is is the top
bacterial toxin that affects this
vesicle transport transport and causes
the death of hundreds of thousands of
children each year
that's one example we use also in the
mutagen children with with high degree
of inflammation we use the analysis of
vesicle transport in the diagnostics and
based on these findings we decide
treatments so yes they have clinical
implications and there are I think
genetic disturbances rare diseases but
there are genetic disorders in this
machinery one of them causes severe
immune defect as dr. hunter mentioned
with hyper inflammation and other one
leads to mainly affect the brain and is
to epilepsy and mental retardation so
there are there are clear medical
implications
so let's see if there are any more
questions seldom you encounter
journalists please so they're clear
medical implications but so has this
discovery led to new medicines or is it
just a way of understanding how the
disease works is it still early stages
in what way it has not led to any
medicines yet but it has led to
Diagnostics but as yawning is said these
discoveries are on the basic machinery
others have applied them to
understanding or developing diagnostics
please diabetes you have the implication
for diabetes that we know is insulin is
produced in the pancreas and it's
released in a calcium sensitive manner
and so this machinery operates in the
release of insulin into the bloodstream
the machinery also works in tissues that
respond to insulin the hormone that
mediates sugar uptake and so it's a
fundamental process in in all cells and
that has really led to a greater
understanding of disease pathogenesis
and prospective treatments are there
more questions
it's almost like lecturing to Swedish
undergraduate students you haven't asked
the question that they always ask will
this come on the exam yes please we have
a question up there hello this is
Mauricio I am a student at Karolinska I
would like to know if these researchers
have done research on the DNA codes
relating with the physiology of the
transport system or only the it's
related with the physiology of the biden
itself only Chile the major discovers
that were awarding our on the protein
machinery that that mediates this fusion
targeting and fusion process in the
calcium sensor and of course they have
published many papers along different
areas related to this process
but check man's approach was genetic as
you are in the presentation he studied
yeast cells with genetic defects
unraveled the machinery yes up there
well you're correct but the actual award
that we're making today the recognition
is on the traffic process please stop
down here yep
question 2nd row you mentioned the
central nervous system could you give an
example of disease that is connected
with these mechanisms I think actually
we we mentioned the the tetanus because
that is related to the to the nervous
system and effect affecting the the
muscles so this is associated with with
the nervous system yes well there is a
disease called botulism which is also
related to to the nervous system this
isn't the same way that there are
bacteria that produce toxins and they
destroy this vesicle transport and that
causes potentially fatal disease or a
fatal disease and we can actually use
this toxin also to treat children that
have spaz disc paralysis or dystonia and
the muscles to release tension in these
muscles so it's used therapeutically as
well okay do we have further questions
if not then I think we'll close here and
there will be as I said opportunities
for interviews for all of you who have
requested interviews with Nobel
Committee members thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you
well this year we have awarded a
fundamental discovery in cell physiology
for vesicle traffic a major transport
system in the cell at the press
conference I got the impression that
this prize people were a bit quiet was
have many people been waiting for this
price people have been aware of this
work you know for decades and you know
the work started in the 1970s and it
sort of built throughout the years so in
some ways I'm surprised that it wasn't
you know more more of a obvious choice
but so it's a fundamental discovery of
cell physiology and it was not entirely
easy for these investigators when they
started so Schekman for example did
yeast genetics and Rahman was doing
biochemistry in itself in a test tube
and suit off was doing biochemistry and
some functional studies with animal
models so think of a cell is sort of a
Factory and it needs to produce proteins
and they need to shuttle these proteins
in cargo from one work station to the
next
so each protein can get a little bit
better refine along the way the
fundamental discovery here is how the
packages the molecules that cargo is
shuttled from one compartment in the
cell to the other and how these
molecules can be also exported from the
cell so it's that process which we have
awarded the Nobel prizes so what were if
you should the great the key
breakthroughs that make them more
durable prize those two young men what
is it
the queasy stuff so Schekman used East
genetics and he was studying
temperatures sent in sensitive mutant
yeast and he could morphologically with
with a microscope see that some of the
vesicles in the mutant youths were
building up in certain parts of the cell
he understood that that disturbed the
traffic and he went on to identify the
genes that control this traffic that was
a pretty bold approach because at the
time people didn't necessarily think
that studies of yeast would be of
relevance for mammals Rothman took a
really bold approach he studied this
process in a test-tube
now that approach was met with some
skepticism because people thought that
this traffic would be dependent upon the
proximity of the compartments with each
other
therefore you theoretically wouldn't be
able to break up the cell because you'd
need to have an int Excel Rothman broke
up the cells and study this in a
test-tube and he could show that even in
a reconstituted system he could build up
this interaction between proteins the
protein machinery and study the traffic
of his vesicles in broken cells and
Schekman when he came on the scene he
recognized that calcium could be a
sensor suit off yes correct suit off
suit suit off came on the scene he
recognized that calcium could be a
sensor and he was faced with a situation
where all the building blocks were
unknown and so his job was to really put
functionality and understand what are
the building blocks said the calcium
binds to and how does that release
vesicles in a temporally a controlled
manner
the automobile states that the prices
should be awarded to those who confer
the greatest benefit on mankind so in
what way does this prize fulfill this
cotillion
well that's true for all of the prizes
and new knowledge about how we how we
are in the world is of great benefit
from having this again is fundamental so
physiology so the knowledge that we're
gaining from this is applicable to all
cells from yeast to humans showing how
ancient this is and what these
individuals have done is they've
uncovered this machinery this mechanism
and that is allowed us to understand
basic physiology but it's also allowed
us to have some insight into disease
progression and prospective treatments
so it's a pretty great benefit to
mankind
we should perspective treatments in to
the destiny even if something one area
when this great so understanding the
treatments better would allow you to
focus on the machinery and potentially
come up with drugs for example diabetes
it's a disease where insulin is not
released from the pancreas appropriately
so this is controlled with also the
calcium so theoretically one can work in
that area and develop pharmaceuticals to
improve insulin release in tissues like
muscle you have an uptake of sugar into
those cells theoretically one could work
on trying to target that machinery to
have a better interaction of you
transport proteins to take up sugar and
feed the muscle with the sugar glucose
so there's a lot of examples of where
this confused
why was this price ever awarded this
year well it's a long journey in terms
of the vetting and how we work and this
one is mature and we you know we felt
that we had a fundamental discovery that
was Nobel prize-worthy
and so this is why we're here today to
talk about these laureates so these
young people what you right now how
would you explain the importance of this
prize to a sailing grade school students
okay so if you can imagine that you were
gonna go to school and you were gonna
take the bus and the bus showed up but
there was no sign on that bus to tell
you where it was going to take you all
those signs on the buses disappeared so
you'd get into the bus without having
any idea of where it might take you it
might take you to your school but it
might take you to your parents workplace
so imagine that you'd be Miss sorted and
that's a little bit what this process is
because of this process the passengers
the cargo they get to the right place
the school at the right time so you're
not late and you don't end up at the
playground or at your parents workplace
or somewhere else where you're not
supposed to be so this whole process
helps the cells sort proteins so the
information is moved to the right place
that's the state of knowledge in this
field at this time a little bit of what
I said to you before when when Schekman
started people were skeptical of the
idea of using a yeast model people were
unsure that you'd be able to really even
do these experiments when Rockman
started it was incredibly bold he broke
up the cells studied this in a test-tube
people were skeptical they didn't think
it could work even with the suit off
work you know the molecules were not on
the table so when did the scientific
community realize the significance of
these findings a scientist I think are
clever to catch on to what's new in the
field and people have really been
actively engaged in this area for
decades this is a tough area of science
it's been really a tough problem to
solve and so many individuals have been
working in different parts of it so if
you turn our attention to the laureates
James Rothman Ben Chapman and Tomas you
don't know do you know them yourself I
don't know them at all personally and
I've heard James Rothman lecture but I
don't have any interactions with them
and I'm not collaborating with them but
I'm aware of Eisley I'm aware of their
work do you have any idea I mean those
findings that there are awarded today
no.8 is like this what do you what do
they work on now you know so some of the
important work is even coming even today
you know so we have some papers that
have been published in the 90s and the
2000s relevance for this work so all of
them are active scientists all of them
are completely engaged in their projects
and they're moving these questions
forward today and personally
what makes you such a stiff at this
point I just think it's really fantastic
I mean it's so beautiful the
organization of this traffic in the cell
is just phenomenal and the fact that
cells really require this otherwise they
basically can't survive it's just
phenomenal how cells are able to move
this protein machine or proteins from
one place to the other so I mean I just
think the cell biology the cell
physiology is really beautiful has the
Nobel commit to being able to reach any
other laureates so there has been a
telephone conversation between yeren
Hanson and Randy Schekman and James
Rothman and suit off hasn't we haven't
been able to reach him but we're in
where we're working at oh you know very
humbled delighted surprised you know you
know I'm sure it's a moment of pause for
them thank you very much Aloha
[Music]